joe biden today is going to be making
some of the biggest foreign policy news
really in a long time as far as the
united states is concerned
joe biden will be withdrawing all u.s
troops
from afghanistan starting very soon
and to be completed by september 11th of
this year
the washington post can now report uh
that will be 20 years to the day
since the 911 2001 attacks
uh joe biden who we were told by donald
trump and even by some on the left
would start wars was some kind of
bloodthirsty war monger
would never bring troops home would send
more troops to more places
joe biden is going to do what george w
bush barack obama and donald trump
could not do or at least did not do now
i know that
some of you will be saying well hold on
a second it was going to happen may 1st
now it's going to be september 11.
that's that's a delay what's going on
uh remember the backstory of that uh the
trump administration
negotiated a may first deadline
with the taliban last year when joe
biden came into office
he did something that i think is
generally smart he came in and said
he didn't say because the trump
administration was so incompetent in
every way but joe biden came in and said
i'm going to review all ongoing projects
and their associated timelines and dates
i'm pausing and reviewing before
committing
to either doing the thing donald trump
started to do or not
this included pausing and evaluating the
may 1st
plan there were things about the may
first plan
that were real question marks including
how exactly would the withdrawal be done
who has been uh coordinated with in
terms of this withdrawal
and the the sort of cynical
interpretation from some
was biden is pausing the may first
withdrawal because he doesn't really
want to leave
he wants to stay forever he may even
send more troops
in this particular case and we evaluate
other cases
on their merits in this particular case
it appears that joe biden
really was just skeptical that donald
trump did anything right
and he wanted to evaluate this plan for
himself
as a result it won't be may but it's
going to be september
it will take four extra months i'd
rather
biden do it competently and have it take
four more months
than simply do it the way trump planned
likely
incompetently much like everything else
that donald trump did
now in terms of numbers officially there
are 2500 u.s
troops left in afghanistan the real
number
is more like 3 500 there are also 7 000
foreign forces mostly nato troops
we don't know exactly what happens with
those other troops at this point in time
but joe biden will be holding
a public event today it may have already
happened by the time you listen to
today's show or watch this clip where
maybe he will
outline that importantly joe biden's
plan for withdrawal from afghanistan
is not conditions based we are simply
getting out and a senior administration
official
said to the washington post that a
conditions-based
plan would be a quote recipe for staying
forever in afghanistan that would be
very bad
the u.s is going to draw down to zero by
september 11th
regardless of conditions now we've
previously
said or asked the question how far does
american responsibility
go in places where we enter
and things break the us military goes in
things break and then we are responsible
at least to some degree you break it you
bought it as sort of the general idea
how long do you have to stay
until you can say well we now we are
getting out even if it's not
totally fixed there's very varied
opinions about this and
and much validity in different ways
joe biden has made a decision that the
limit is september 11
2021. of course we will believe it if
and when it happens
but this has been trillions of dollars
hundreds of thousands dead
millions certainly affected by it it is
time to go
trump promised it he couldn't get it
done during his presidency
biden is at least apparently going to do
it
now what will the trump supporters say
they seemed to support it
when it was donald trump who announced
that this is what he was going to be
doing
they should still support it i can't
imagine they would now be rooting i
don't know for the taliban or for
whoever
uh if they supported it happening when
it was trump that announced it
you would imagine if they were
consistent they would support it now as
well
some are already saying that september
11th is too soon though
now how does that make sense if may 1st
was okay
how does taking four extra months make
it
too soon uh you'd have to ask them now
some practical questions
will afghanistan destabilize
after u.s troops leave we don't know it
it's possible that that will happen will
iran get more involved
maybe in fact iran getting involved
could be
sort of part of restructuring and
getting back to
the iran nuclear deal we don't know yet
that's another possibility
it's premature to assume that al qaeda
simply rises again or that the islamic
state
rises again the taliban is very opposed
to the islamic state al qaeda has a
little presence
sure al qaeda could try to regroup in
afghanistan
but there are easier places at this
point for al qaeda to try to regroup
so what we know for now is the date is
september 11
2021 let's see if the phase drawdown
starts and let's see if we are out
in what is essentially just under five
months from today
but this is a good decision and it is a
major foreign policy decision
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at
privacy.com pacman